I appreciate ya give me the quiz okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's actually quite good megamix I
don't think they'll find you well don't
do that you'll be fine
give us a hint you two are kind of close
nearby I'll call off so called yeah
South called us so cold again warmer can
warmer getting warmer getting warmer and
warmer good
I don't know which one of you is okay
you're just kind of like you know you're
simmering okay okay yeah well I didn't
know that was a room so now my fault I
didn't even know is a room the newspaper
moved when you move the other thing I
thought it was him well thanks so much
for that
they're back and trading right there
so that's illegal in some countries okay
with that oh Jesus
this is serious problem I'm in serious
[ __ ] oh my god run does something right
hey mate I smell you where are you oh
hey buddy
a fox you're [ __ ] up Hey
I was so bad baby that was know where I
am I can't see you so if you come near
me I won't be able to know I'm not
Marc sightings like just any word he
says secondly he likes to be big objects
in plane so know you very well that
worked for me before yelling this I'm
not doing that
he's no a big ok yes I'm nice time will
be a big object I tell you I will be a
big object this promise not knocked over
why I would like you to pinky promise
your webcam with me right now
oh I get what you did Marc that's really
good that's ready I'm pinky promising
something just the webcam right there
hey there we go there we go thank you
they'll have to see both of our videos
to make they'll line it up like yes can
we do it one more time all right all
three I'm doing it right now
oh okay no countdown baby go there we go
that's beautiful thank you it's quite
amazing cuz you guys were almost looking
each other in the gay men as well yeah I
can see I can see the e both in the same
end it's a good spot who's gonna make it
it's good I'm not telling you what you
I'm not gonna say it so what you ask is
ticket yeah and it's kind of obvious so
there no need to be clues here there's
no need for you guys have walked past in
many a time already you are so dumb so
dumb
oh my god guys Oh
oh I say I'm not actually almost onto
you but then he just dismiss what I saw
the screen shake did someone launch a
grenade
[Laughter]
yeah I don't think so I don't think you
can turn into sokka's Canyon oh my god
oh my god you guys you guys are so so so
so gonna kick yourself in the teeth
yeah you guys I'm not giving this away
like muck I want you to go dance at
night I wanna do dance it was like a
pixel off wasn't it
I like this I think this could be a good
one yeah yeah we're doing good run okay
they we're never made number three in
this room up we're that no I don't think
so I think you're being played for a
fool two watermelons underneath the desk
no sir Mike I hope he kept to his pinky
promise I think I think I'll try Disney
hazard I did you didn't say how big
though
yeah you know it's gotta be at least
like bigger than a breadbox bigger than
a breadbox a bigger than life bigger
than like I'm so big so big I applaud
you guys for a full I'm long gone
it's obvious she does this enough
no no story tell the truth this one time
I believe that manga mix is telling the
truth I will never believe nothing trust
issues you're never gonna get far in
life you know this right
I mean video games III see you oh there
you go
I what wait huh don't confuse me like
that no you're gone oh oh good I'm gone
[Music]
I I was in the room with the fire no way
ya know I told these other looked weird
the question is what looks weird yeah
[Music]
okay you've won knock you got this about
this no big boy me so many times they've
passed by me yes he's a moderately sized
object I would say I said big with the
pinky promise
he's much bigger than I was secret I'll
tell you a secret I did the same trick I
did before I have replaced an item yeah
oh god I went to great lengths to hide
that one hey you two gotta be
watermelons in the exact same place
again
kazow is who we wouldn't be that silly
it might just Mel's a bit like a traffic
cone to me a trafficker there's more
furniture in this room than there was
earlier
Oh like a secret bed here by the way for
you a cone what if I told you I was by
the fireplace oh yeah
are you lying if I'm newspaper are you
kids why would they lie sounds like a
lie is the weather outside frightful but
far so delightful if you got no place we
should do like a Christmas profit
special oh my god really
[Music]
[Music]
don't be don't care